il faut qu'il y est une négociation
c'est pourquoi mesdames et messieurs les
députés j'ai pris la décision de nommer
les coulisses de la république et ses
secrets
les grandes idées et les petites
combines rien de tout cela ne lui est
étranger
jean pierre soisson est un vieux
briscard de la politique
les français attendent il adore au delà
du déluge des mots et de la confusion
des esprits
il a servi l'état sous quatre présidents
qui l'a côtoyé de près il a participé à
huit gouvernement a été élu député dix
fois de suite et il fut maire d'auxerre
pendant 27 ans au crépuscule de sa vie
politique
jean pierre soisson se confie enfin sur
ce parcours parfois décrié mais hors du
commun
j'ai connu en 50 ans tout le spectre
politique français
de la droite à la gauche et je crois que
la période que j'ai connue est révolu on
ne pourra plus être maire d'une ville
pendant 30 ans et donc je suis un peu un
dinosaure de la politique
ce qui caractérise jean pierre soisson
c'est d'avoir été l'un des tout premiers
à passer de la droite à la gauche
il incarne l'histoire d'un courant
politique aujourd'hui au pouvoir mais
longtemps insaisissable le centre s'il y
avait une devise républicaine de jean
pierre soisson ce serait générosité
audace exigences
c'est un artiste politique jean pierre
soisson d'ailleurs plus qu'un animal
politique parce qu'ils aiment l'art
politique et il aime profondément
comme d'ailleurs il aime celles et ceux
qui l'entourent
il a parfois même beaucoup de tendresse
pour ses adversaires il ne parle pas
d'ennemis il parle d'adversaires c'est
déjà assez rassurant il n'était pas
dépasser par les fonctions qu'on lui
donne et il avait la taille qu'il
fallait donc c'était un bon ministre
vous savez avoir été un bon maire un bon
président de région et un bon ministre
pour une seule personne
c'est déjà assez satisfaisant
la famille soissons est installé à
auxerre depuis toujours au début du 20e
siècle
l'arrière grand père tient un grand
magasin dans le centre de la ville les
auxerrois commence à aller chez soi sont
pour y découvrir le dernier chic
parisien bien connu de la bourgeoisie
auxerroises les soissons sont déjà des
notables
mon grand père a été un des chefs
d'entreprise modèle en 1936 sous le
front populaire il avait créé un comité
d'entreprise
il s'est occupé du logement de tous ces
ouvriers et mon père a été président de
la chambre de commerce sera construit
l'aérodrome d'auxerre a développé le le
port d'auxerre si bien que je suis dans
une longue continuité de ces rois hors
service de tous
jean pierre lui né en 1934 à auxerre
pour guignon par son père les accents du
sud de sa mère ne seront pas sans
influence ma mère était morte et elle
recevait comme personne au monde ne
savait de savait recevoir
je rappelle les fêtes de noël à auxerre
et lé 13 desserts provençaux qui
honorait tout table marseillaise et que
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie est là à la
bouche du rhône oreilles c'était une
femme admirable
[Musique]
comme pour nombre de fils de bonne
famille la scolarité du jeune homme se
poursuit au lycée jacques amyot à
auxerre il se passionne alors pour une
langue morte
j'avais un professeur de latin
extraordinaire et les coûts et et en
latin on est allé sur les traces de
césar et de vercingétorix avec le db
locally co2 de ses arômes 1 et à ses
songes parler couramment latins ces
années là le jeune homme se prend
d'admiration pour une figure de la
troisième république
le bourguignon paul bert père de l'école
publique et laïque phillies et d'autres
écoles c'est notre église à nous c'est
dans le village y aura la mairie et
l'école face off à l'église à cette
époque à auxerre une autre figure locale
est un religieux
l'abbé deschamps qui donnera son nom au
stade de football
l'abbé deschamps est alors un personnage
influent pour les familles catholiques
de la ville
et comme beaucoup d'autres le jeune soit
son porte le maillot de l'équipe de
l'association pour la jeunesse
auxerroises l'abbé deschamps il a créé
la jia pour tenir la jeunesse d'auxerre
dans le catholicisme
enfin la partie qui en était puisque
parallèlement il y avait trois clubs
laïque
à l'époque nous nous trouvions en face
de l'équipe du stade auxerrois et j'ai
des souvenirs corps on t'a plu plus dans
les mollets de l'équipe adverse que dans
le ballon
[Musique]
au milieu des années 50
la france est engagée dans ce qui ne
s'appelle pas encore la guerre d'algérie
comme beaucoup d'appelés de son âge
le jeune homme doit partir
j'ai choisi de partir en algérie j'ai
choisi le 3ème régiment de chasseurs
d'afrique commandé par le colonel argoud
et est polytechnicien qui avait fait
l'indochine et quand je suis arrivé un
dialogue étonnant façon vous
désapprouvez ce que l'armée fait en
algérie
oui mon colonel le chef de harkat vient
de mourir et ce que j'ai accepté de le
remplacer
oui mon colonel le sous-lieutenant
soissons va donc diriger des harkis
algériens enrôlé par l'armée française
contre le fln pendant deux ans il sera
au coeur des opérations 2h02 de combat
de même de deux corps à corps quand le
feu s'ouvre on peut pas savoir qui sera
le courageux qui n'osera pas ça ne se
commande pas la peur il faut petit à
petit l'apprivoiser
plus partir d'algues verrez comme
officier de cavalerie
ils m ont trouvé là bas aussi comme
comme bâtisseur créant une infirmerie
créant une école des maisons projet les
familles et c'est ce travail de
bâtisseur en liaison directe avec la
population musulmane simard qui m'a
passionné aussi
à la fin de la guerre en 1962 de
nombreux harkis abandonnés à leur sort
par la france seront exécutés par les
indépendantistes algériens à l'origine
un certain nombre de lois qui ont
amélioré leurs conditions et je reçois
comme une blessure je fait que la france
est abandonnée des hommes qui avait tout
quitté pour la rejoindre
battus pour elle sur les a laissé
tourner à 60 noeuds en les exposant à la
torture et à la mort je te griller est
une des choses les plus est plus forte
que j'ai vécu une mission secrète au
moment du push en 61 avoué est devenu
l'un des chefs de l'ol et il m'a écrit
rome demandant de venir le rejoindre
comme son directeur de cabinet j'ai
refusé j'ai porté l'étendard du 3e
régiment russie en afrique et pour moins
de rapprocher le drapeau de la
république il n'est pas question que je
choisi d'autres voies
après ses études à l'ena jean pierre
soisson entre à la cour des comptes
suite aux accords d'evian il doit
retourner en algérie
il échappe alors miraculeusement un
attentats de l'oas avec mon épouse
revenez du fait du cinéma et au fait on
se retrouver prise hors prise dans une
bombe de l'ol la voiture a monté la m va
mettre 50 sur le son de serre plati
j'aurais connu ainsi en algérie les
balles du flnc les bombes de leurs aises
georges pompidou est premier ministre la
france est en pleine décolonisation
le jeune énarque ne pense alors pas
encore à la politique mais une rencontre
va s'avérer décisive
le président du sénégal léopold sédar
senghor l'un des dirigeants africains
les plus influents le prend en amitié et
lui donne un conseil ce serait énorme a
dit jean-pierre vous ne voyez faire une
carrière politique à auxerre je crois et
il a appelé proprio qui m'a reçu du jour
après je suis sûr en tout cas que
l'opinion de jean pierre soisson est
alors classé à droite à l'aise devant
les caméras ils affrontent lors d'un
débat à un jeune socialiste en devenir
michel rocard la parole je suis un peu
comme michel rocard je n'aime pas le
terme de technocrates pour moi le
technocrate fait un peu à monsieur qui a
envie du pouvoir politique et qui a peur
du suffrage universel
sa première bataille politique
soissons va l'amener dans sa ville
pompidou alors premier ministre lui
demandent de croiser le fer aux
législatives de 67 contre un socialiste
proche de mitterrand il perd défaite
honorable mais défaite quand même le
jeune homme fait alors une nouvelle
rencontre marquante
il se rapproche des deux gars fort son
premier maître en politique
appelés à travailler à ses côtés au
ministère de l'agriculture
soissons s'engouffre dans le sillage de
cet ancien président du conseil sous la
quatrième république
edgar faure girouettes politiques dits
ses ennemis inventeur du centrisme
rétorque que ses disciples habile trait
d'union en tout cas entre radicaux et
gaullistes on peut dire qu'elle garforth
s'était probablement au début de la vème
république
la personnalité de droite modérée non
gaullistes la plus attractive pour un
jeune énarque ambitions ils étaient
venus décorer mon père à poitiers les
gars forts pour la légion d'honneur il
était arrivé avec deux heures de retard
il avait commencé en dix ans par rapport
à mon programme que 20 mai par rapport
au programme peuvent étudier avance une
heure en avance ce qui me donne le
sentiment d'être à l'heure il avait
toujours des petites histoires racontées
c'était la somme d'un esprit et d'une
culture
j'admirais en lui la la souveraineté de
l'intelligence l'art de rechercher à un
compromis un mélange de bonhomie et de
grandeur de fidélité aussi car en 68 il
est ministre et contre le président de
la république qui l'a soutenu ma
candidature plus dois tout daniel
bendit et sept autres étudiants de
nanterre comparaissent devant le conseil
de discipline à la sorbonne
la manifestation organisée par l'unef
s'amplifie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'affrontement la manifestation
sera 600 blessés 4 lorsqu'éclate la
révolte de mai 68
jean pierre soisson à 33 ans il se
retrouve au coeur des événements pour
calmer la rue de gaulle et pompidou
nomme tu en urgence edgar faure au
ministère de l'éducation
soissons le suis ils vont alors négocier
avec les têtes pensantes du mouvement
étudiant
une nouvelle loi d'autonomie des
universités ce qui jetait ou qui avaient
jeté des pavés dans la rue venez la nuit
un peu comme des conspirateurs discuter
avec nous les articles de ce qui sera là
la grande loi de réforme des deux
guerres fort pour rappel souvenirs
incroyables il entré par la petite porte
ils allaient dans une salle où qui
éclairait des bougies vos sandwichs au
beaujolais
on a ainsi établi quelques articles de
la loi d'orientation mai 68 était plus
culturel que politique
c'était une volonté de rompre avec le
moralisme ambiant d' de mettre fin aussi
à la période collienne et finalement
d'abattre les hiérarchie verticale s du
flair politique s de l'opportunisme jean
pierre soisson va démontrer par la suite
une belle habileté à se ranger du côté
des vainqueurs
quel que soit leur camp politique ainsi
au début des années soixante dix après
avoir été élu député
soissons se rapproche d'un homme
politique en deux volets
valéry giscard d'estaing valéry giscard
d'estaing aime à rappeler qu'il faut et
contracté la vie publique
l'homme politique doit être un homme
d'action un homme naturel sans artifice
même si cela peut choquer certains tous
les meetings de giscard commencer par le
chant du départ khl la foule reprenait
la victoire en chantant nous ouvrent la
barrière de la liberté guide nos pas
soissons c'est la carte jeunes de la
campagne présidentielle de giscard en
1974 il a 40 ans et il travaille alors
avec un futur premier ministre jean
pierre raffarin est son collaborateur
est proche de lui c'est à la fois un
bonheur parce qu'il ya cette proximité
chaleureuse mais c'est aussi quelque
chose de difficile parce qu'il est
extraordinairement exigeant et que si
vous n'êtes pas au niveau
il le vous dis gentiment mais vous le
comprenez clairement la victoire de
lescar est une sorte de marche
triomphale au trône souvenirs
merveilleux d'un commencement un peu le
sentiment que me donnait emmanuel macron
remontée d'un commencement avec un
souffle nouveau avec des équipes
nouvelles avec des députés différents
l'expert a gagné sur la volonté de
changement est cependant il n'a gagné
que 2 425 mille voix c'était une sorte
de changement sans risque avec ce slogan
qui rassemble tout le monde
le changement dans la continuité mais il
y avait cet appel terre ce besoin
d'ouvrir les fenêtres de la france c'est
un des plus jeunes candidats que la
france ait connu c'est un homme qui
cherche à pacifier la société a dépassé
les clivages c'est tout de même cela le
giscard de 1974 qui à certains égards
d'ailleurs rappelle le macron que nous
connaissons en 2017 ya de très nombreux
points communs et ça n'est qu'après à la
fin de son septennat que giscard va
devenir ce
d'heure un peu contraint un peu
traditionnelle un peu aristocratique
mais le septennat giscard c'est un
septennat de grands changements ou le
monde politique rencontre la société
française telle qu'elle a changé après
mai 68
lorsque jacques chirac devient premier
ministre
il nomme jean pierre soisson secrétaire
d'état aux universités la continuité en
quelque sorte du travail amorcé aux
côtés d'edgar faure pendant mai 68 on le
voyait heureux et on était heureux de
voir un ministre jeunes à la tête de ce
qui est le média le plus important pour
la jeunesse c'était une période
exceptionnelle pour lui parce qu'on
voyait qu'il avait le bonheur de
l'action qu'il avait tant voulue pour
lequel il avait mis tant d'ambition mais
l'expérience tourne court
en janvier 76 il est muté à la formation
professionnelle
j'ai voulu aller trop loin trop fort
trop proches redoutent des grands
intellectuels a été vidée pour une
raisons factuelles
je ne mettais pas proposer un
enseignement de la sexualité à
l'université de paris xiii attendait on
enchaîne la sexualité prescrit à l'école
maternelle mais le fait en 1974 dans une
grande université
il en était pas question c'est à partir
de ces années là que sa firme le profil
politique modérée de jean pierre soisson
l'union des droites vole en éclats
chirac démissionne de matignon gaulliste
et giscardien se déchirent
jean pierre soisson est l'homme qui
monte
giscard le charge de créer un nouveau
parti pour grignoter le territoire des
gaullistes du rpr
c'est la naissance du parti républicain
cela peut paraître étonnant mais la
puissance du vent ce jeudi a eu des
conséquences politiques
le chapiteau sous lequel devait se tenir
les journées des républicains
indépendants à fréjus s'est effondrée ce
matin au moment de sa mise en place
blessant légèrement
cette personne cela a retardé
l'ouverture de ce congrès qui accueille
dix mille personnes
nous avons fondé effectivement à fréjus
à nouveau parti le parti républicain pr
n'a seuls mouvements sont venus se
fondre toutes les familles giscardienne
comme on dit à notre objectif est simple
il est de rassembler dans la majorité
tous ceux qui soutiennent sans équivoque
l'action de réforme du président de la
république c'est la naissance politique
du centre le parti républicain devient
l'une des composantes de l'udf la
coalition contrôlée par giscard
les hommes du centre existe le centre a
du mal à exister avec les institutions
de la vème république telles qu'elles
sont parce que globalement elles sont
manichéenne parce que au deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle il ya deux
candidats il ya le pour et le contre et
donc naturellement il y a deux grands
blocs et la victoire aller vers ceux qui
au centre joueront à l'ouverture le
centre c'est plus c'est plus un rêve une
réalité politique
il a besoin de s'accrocher à quelque
chose à gauche ou à droite
je pense que soissons comme beaucoup de
gens du centre et de droite modérée
était fait pour être macro nist et que
macron même si vient d'une gauche
modérée était fait pour travailler avec
des centristes et donc qu'il y avait là
si j'ose dire
un mariage naturel et vos fonds j'en
perçois son était prêt macro nist sans
le savoir et macron je ne dirais pas
qu'ils étaient soit sony stands sachant
mai
c'est une fraction de la famille de ceux
qui le soutiennent
le député d'auxerre apprend à se rendre
indispensable
pendant la campagne des législatives de
1978 il reçoit le président à auxerre
les giscardiens ont alors deux
adversaires la gauche mais aussi les
gaullistes les français attendent ils
attendent au delà du déluge des mots et
de la confusion une attente mais aussi
une certitude celle que vous êtes
monsieur le président selon l'expression
même du général de gaulle l'homme en
charge de l'essentiel
l'udf de giscard l'emportent de justesse
et soissons est réélu député de l'yonne
surfant sur cette victoire il obtient à
43 ans son premier vrai portefeuille
raymond barre alors premier ministre le
nomme à la jeunesse et aux sports
toute ma vie j'ai vécu j'ai fait du
sport le paie du bus qui joue au tennis
et donc tout naturellement dans les
milieux sportifs
je me suis senti chez moi et ils m'ont
considéré comme l'un des leurs depuis
inauguré chaud pour combien de piscine
mais j'ai pas inaugure éclats avec la
cravate jean oguer plongeurs en
plongeant dans la plupart des suicides
ne france
je fais les grands stades puis tous les
tous les grands matchs rétabli niger qui
m'a passionné
à auxerre le sport c'est le football le
club de la ville dont il est maire et
dans lequel il a joué enfant atteint la
finale de la coupe de france 1979
le président et son ministre des sports
sont en tribunes la france entière
découvre la gia
[Applaudissements]
on est en 2e division et semi
professionnels tous les joueurs
travaillent
on s'entraîne entre midi et deux heures
contre nantes on a fait une partie
magnifique le relever et capitaine serge
mâsse younes avait marqué de la tête
qu'on était un partout à la fin du temps
réglementaire la prolongation a commencé
par une erreur d'arbitrage manifeste on
a pris un but puis après on s'est
écroulé en a pris 4 1 en face à tes
vraiment le début de la popularité de la
jirs
pendant le match je manie marges
lescoeur me dit mais vous êtes ici le
ministre des sports
vous n'êtes pas le maire d'auxerre je
lui ai répondu monsieur le président si
sur le terrain c'était votre équipe de
chamalières qui jouer et bien vous
auriez dans les tribunes la même
attitude que bras finale a dû ces
années-là la crise économique et le
chômage s'installe
figure marquante du septennat giscard
raymond barre ne vient pas du sérail
politique celui que le président
surnomme le meilleur économiste de
france séduit par son sérieux
le centriste soissons qui se verrait
bien là encore s'engouffrer dans son
sillage raymond barre a été à fantastic
premier ministre avec un programme qui
est exactement celui aujourd'hui du
google devant macro la réduction de la
dépense publique donne est plus liberté
aux chefs d'entreprise pour embaucher la
recherche d'un équilibre des échanges
extérieurs et la tenue ce ce programme
contre tous
raymond barre n'est pas à l'aise à
l'assemblée nationale
raymond barre ne va pas aller sur les
marchés serrer des mains
il n'aime pas ça et s'il le fait c'est
malgré lui
cf comment il le fait mal il aurait été
je crois un très grand président de la
république
il n'était pas un bon candidat
1981 le pape jean paul ii vient pour la
première fois en france la république
laïque lui déroule le tapis rouge
et pour jean pierre soisson c'est un
grand souvenir de sa vie de chrétien et
là j'ai vu la chance pour un chrétien
comme moi de recevoir la communion des
mains du pape le lendemain réception à
l'elysée et sous la pluie je faisais des
que avec georges marchais pour gagner le
l'entrée de l'elysée georges marchais me
demande comment deux fois je l'appelais
je lui ai répondu ça perd ou très saint
père il me dit je ferai pas dire ça et
lui dit mais pourquoi vous êtes là parce
que la pologne est un pays communiste
voici georges marchais qui échange
quelques mots avec le pape on ne sait
pas bien sûr ce qu'ils se sont dit car
il n'y avait pas de micros ce matin dans
les salons de l'elysée
hulala lâchant sa deuxième chance feu
l'habitude du pape d'avoir une
conversation dans une embrasure de
fenêtres avec lui avec jean paul 2 6 me
regarde dans les yeux et il me dit vous
êtes ministre de la jeunesse
il faut fournir un emploi aux jeunes
donnez leur des pelles et des pioches
pour construire des autoroutes
j'ai compris ce jour là que la pologne
était vraiment un pays communiste la
victoire de la gauche en 1981 presse
hippique à droite vers la bim la
carrière politique de jean pierre
soisson à prendre une nouvelle tournure
mais 80 c 7 avec 1968 un des deux grands
chocs dans l'histoire de la vème
république avant une troisième qui sera
macron ça fait quand même 23 ans que la
gauche est dans l'opposition ont causé
un choc incroyable et pour les gens
comme jean pierre soisson
c'est aussi un gros choc parce que ils
peuvent se demander s'ils ont choisi le
bon camp pour combien de temps la gauche
c'était le pouvoir et il se retrouve
dans l'opposition il a soutenu giscard
c'est mitterand qui a gagné les
lendemains de défaite son cruel
jean pierre soisson mise sur un nouveau
cheval raymond barre l'ancien premier
ministre de giscard
je suis allé en rendre compte à giscard
lui même voulu été reçus par
son principal collaborateur jean
cerisaie qui m'a tenu les propos
suivants
jean-pierre si tu veux retourner
resserre être maire d'auxerre libre à
toi si tu veux continuer à jouer un rôle
national rappelle toi tu appartiens à
giscard tu appartiens à la maison du roy
soissons rejoint l'équipe l'arist ce
choix va s'avérer décisif après la
victoire de la droite aux législatives
de 1986 lorsque le président mitterrand
affrontera pendant la cohabitation une
situation difficile en nouvelle
calédonie il cherchera des soutiens dans
son opposition modérée
jean pierre soisson sera ce passeur
raymond barre partage l'avis de françois
mitterrand dans sa volonté de recherche
d'une paix entre ces deux communautés
s'est pas du tout là la politique de
bernard pons et c'est les contacts au
sujet de laquelle est de 10 avec avec le
secrétaire général de l'elysée
jean-louis bianco qui monte
progressivement rapproché de l'équipe 2
de l'elysée
[Applaudissements]
al'approche de la présidentielle de 1988
françois mitterrand cherche de nouveaux
alliés au centre l'ouverture c'est le
nom que prend sa nouvelle stratégie
cela implique de débaucher des
centristes qui étaient
traditionnellement dans le camp de la
droite
il fait alors des propositions précises
à jean pierre soisson ici dans son
bureau de la mairie d'auxerre et
immérité j'espère conduire réélu une
politique qui réunira à auxerre
ceux qui votent pour vous et ceux qui
votent pour moi je comprends qu'il sera
candidat qu'il recherchera l'ouverture
qu'une certaine place au fil de ma
proposera d'entrer au gouvernement
jean pierre soisson fait un bourguignon
il al'habitude de compromis c'est un
réaliste et c'est ce que j'appelle un
frontalier
c'est à dire que c'est un homme qui aime
le vin la politique mais qui est capable
de passer d'un vignoble à un autre je
dirais que jean pierre soisson à cette
époque là est fait pour être séduit par
françois mitterrand et que françois
mitterrand
car en plus adore la bourgogne et qui
repèrent vite parce qu'il a du flair
politique ceux qui sont susceptibles de
devenir des interlocuteurs fait ce qu'il
peut pour séduire jean pierre soisson
avec finalement une certaine efficacité
le 8 mai 1988
mitterrand est réélu jean pierre soisson
symbolise cette stratégie d'ouverture
qui a permis la victoire du président
socialiste
il est en position d'obtenir un poste
clé dans le nouveau gouvernement rocard
[Musique]
enoch centriste jeu devient ministre du
travail dans un gouvernement à majorité
socialiste
choix difficile parce que tu es rejeté
parce que tu quittes est une est guère
accepté parce que tu rejoins vraiment
marre avait été lui il aurait fait
l'ouverture il y aurait plus d ministre
socialiste dans le gouvernement
monsieur françois mitterrand a été élu
il fait l'ouverture il est normal que
des ministres centristes apparaissent
dans ce gouvernement il va là où il a
toujours été c'est à dire au centre de
la vie politique française avec ses
propres convictions
c'est la politique qui s'est déplacé
c'est pas tellement jean pierre soisson
je me souviens de l'avoir appelée pour
lui dire que je considérais ça comme la
suite logique de son parcours le fit le
choix de l'ouverture avec l'idée qui a
été constamment la mienne de faire
travailler ensemble des hommes et des
femmes venus d'horizons politiques
différents
c'est je dois reconnaître à michel
rocard la liberté qu'il valait c'est
dans l'élaboration de ses deux
principales lois sur le licenciement
économique et contre l'exclusion
ma deuxième mois sur l'exclusion a été
votée par l'assemblée nationale unanime
à l'exception de député communiste jean
pierre soisson en tant que ministre du
travail ça a été un très bon ministre du
travail parce qu'il avait une capacité à
écouter et les acteurs syndicaux et à
faire un pas vers eux à la à les
convaincre c'est un homme de droite mais
qui ensuite a su transgresser les
frontières
[Musique]
le second septennat mitterrand s'avère
mouvementée parmi les premiers ministres
qui se succèdent à matignon pierre
bérégovoy confié en avril 92 le
ministère de l'agriculture à jean pierre
soisson bérégovoy maire de nevers et
bourguignons lui aussi il montre de la
sympathie pour le maire d'auxerre
souvent il m'appelait le matin de très
bonne heure je me rappelle ma femme qui
disait collerait sur le téléphone sonne
et hier c'est le premier mini c'est au
réveil matin pour l'instant ce dont nous
avons besoin c'est du soutien
huppé et de la représentation nationale
en 1993
les socialistes perdent la majorité à
l'assemblée
c'est le début de la seconde
cohabitation au soir de cette lourde
défaite
pierre bérégovoy jean pierre soisson se
retrouvent dans cette brasserie proche
du palais bourbon
ces dirigeants socialistes revenaient de
la rue solférino où se trouvait le siège
du parti socialiste
ils ont passé à deux mètres à côté de
pierre bérégovoy à nos maîtres au cas
rocade est à saluer
quelques mois plus tard
un coup de tonnerre bouleversent le
monde politique pierre bérégovoy était
tellement usé fatigué accablé il fait
donner la mort samedi en fin
d'après-midi à nevers sur les bords du
canal va appeler les obsèques à nevers
est le discours du président de la
république il faut jeter ce recadrage
russia à auxerre une joie nouvel an
porte bientôt toute la ville lavinia
gagnent enfin la coupe de france sous la
houlette de son entraîneur fétiche
le club est devenu en quelques années
l'une des meilleures équipes de
l'hexagone
quinze ans après sa première finale
l'inamovible guy roux tient enfin une
parole donnée à françois mitterrand qui
j'ai failli vous manqué puisque le 20
avril 80 nous étions à l'entraînement à
château chinon nous l'avions rencontrée
et je lui avais dit écoutez je vous
rendrai visite au parc des princes
s'étend au passé il m'a rendu service
s'est présenté une deuxième fois et nous
sommes là a donc c'est miraculeux mais
c'était une des choses qui faisaient que
toute l'année j'ai cru qu'on irait en
finale et toute l'année j'ai dit à mes
joueurs pour qu'on aille en finale pour
qu'on aille à final on va autrement je
suis un moins que rien
on l'a en fait cinq occasions mais trois
bus une bonne moyenne
et c'est ça rend la victoire assez
logique mais très cruel pour notre
adversaire
j'étais ministre des sports pour la
première finale
et puis on l'a pas eue mais là c'est
quinze ans de travail et 15 heures de
travail à partir du centre de formation
l'aja s'est d'abord afin de permettre en
tout je crois que nous avons formés
alors je ne compte pas par exemple
laurent blanc ou silvestre je peins de
ce que nous avons formés nous allons
former dix sept joueurs de l'équipe de
france a et en tout avec les pièces
rapportées y en a eu plus de 25
tout au long de son second mandat le
président mitterrand vient régulièrement
en bourgogne partager avec jean pierre
soisson les plaisirs d'une bonne table
ils reçoivent ensemble le chancelier
helmut kohl à saint père sous vézelay
quand il ya eu la grande visite de
helmut kohl avait gelé avec
françois-mitterand jean pierre était là
présent et avait fait tout les
préparatifs avant pour recevoir les deux
présidents c'est un homme qui est proche
des cuisiniers et qui a un goût je
dirais presque exacerbé pour les les
plats rustiques et en cela il se
rapprocher assez du goût de 800
d'ailleurs françois mitterrand est un
homme de la terre
il mange comme un paysan très lentement
j'ai bu et champignons oui il aimait les
truffes avec françois mitterrand je vous
parlais peu politique
il me parlait littérature et sa culture
était immense mais c'était au fond celle
d'un jeune bourgeois de province très
catholique comme eux je l'était et donc
ses références étaient mauriac bernanos
mais nous avions une différence il avait
une passion pour sa john perse
alors que je préférais rené char
j'ai toujours pensé que ces discours
s'inspirer de la scansion des verts
lesage une perf fin 1995
françois mitterrand qui vient de quitter
l'elysée est de plus en plus malade
les deux hommes ne se reverront plus
pour les fêtes de noël mort d un look en
fait le président devait se rendre à soi
je devais le retrouver pour le 1er
janvier
puis jean glavany ma m'appeler nous
rentrons rentrons le président ne va pas
bien je suis rentré moi aussi j'ai
appris sa mort dans dans l'avion qui m a
amené à paris je suis allée saluer dès
le lendemain ça sa dépouille dans
l'appartement veulent annuler frais que
le play où il réside et une forme tous
absents d'ouverture aux ouvertures sont
fenêtre et je me rappelle que daniel
danielle mitterrand avait dit à l'époque
trouve pas fait maintenant ce qu'il y a
derrière le mur à faire escale à auxerre
chez jean pierre soisson notable
incontournable est devenu au fil des ans
un passage obligatoire pour tous les
politiques en campagne dans la course à
la présidentielle de 1995
la droite est encore une fois d une les
deux candidats gaulliste viennent
frapper chacun la porte du maire
d'auxerre
jacques chirac l'adversaire d'hier est
devenu le nouvel ami politique de jean
pierre soisson son cheval de bataille
c'était à l'époque la fracture sociale
en campagne il écoute je ne tiens pas de
longs discours
il boit du coulanges hybois 2,3 corona
la conception de l'europe n'est pas tout
à fait celle que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui une force de la nature d'un
entraîneur naturellement contre balladur
jamais voté chirac l'autre arrive là
c'est le mois suivant balladur à auxerre
balladur arrive sérieux là sial tous les
élus de l'yonne
cravate et derrière des tables qui sont
là pour l'écouter le préfet ou en
uniforme dont mais à sa droite
silence oui monsieur le premier ministre
roulez vous a un peu le chablis non je
ne vois pas de vin blanc
est-ce que je puisse vous proposer à un
verre d'iran sic et le meilleur rouge de
la région
non je ne vois que du bordeaux une est
en campagne électorale en bourgogne se
resserre attendaient que je veux est
pliée à vue
je fais monter à la tribune je les dis
ceci les chaînes premier ministre fils
vous appartient de lever la malédiction
la vème république un chef de
gouvernement en exercice n'a jamais pu
gagner une élection présidentielle puis
je peux sur ainsi sa part ça peut
améliorer le chemin
jacques chirac est élu au passage jean
pierre soisson va vivre une grande
émotion avec le club de football de son
coeur à auxerre il ya quarante mille
habitants mais il ya surtout 25 mille
supporters et hier soir c'est toute la
vie grimée en vue et blanc qui s'étaient
donné rendez vous pour fêter joyeusement
plus du double de son club 1996
c'est le triomphe de l'association pour
la jeunesse auxerroises
le petit club entraîné par guy roux est
devenu grand doublé coupe-championnat
historique et c'est plus que le stade de
l'abbé-deschamps presque est pétrifié
par la tête
dernière minute du match corentin
martins inscrit le dernier but du
championnat
les buts de la victoire dans le nouveau
championnat les auxerrois s'étaient
habitués à à la gloire de serre sur le
plan politique il trouver normal que les
ministres des affaires sociales de toute
l'europe débarque dans la ville et sur
le plan sportif il trouver normal que
auxerre joue contre arsenal dortmund
l'ajax d'amsterdam
il y tient on reçoit l'ajax la semaine
prochaine comme sûrs et prendre un café
chez chez le le ministre du poids et
maintenant que l'épopée d'une certaine
manière est terminée eh bien ils
s'aperçoivent le chemin qui avait été
celui de guéroult et des sommets
auxquels il avait entraîné l'agira c'est
l'heure de gloire d'auxerre et c'est
tout un symbole celui d'une période
auxerroises ou football et politique
était au sommet hier où ça personnages
étonnants
il a lu les mythologies africaine et il
a eu david l'équipe
une attitude très particulière
il ne veut pas être aimé au contraire il
veut que lorsque ses joueurs entrent sur
le terrain il le déteste
donc ils les amènent un état de tension
qui les conduit à produire le meilleur
d'eux mêmes c'est tout à fait étonnant
c'était un aiguillon pour lui j'ai dû
beaucoup le gêner mais à six mois de
l'élection s'était terminée c'était
neutralité totale en façade et soutien
personnel par derrière je peux quand
même vous avouer que dans la première
campagne électorale en 67 et bien j'ai
que passer quelques nuits à coller des
affiches dans la puisaye et en 68 qui a
été la deuxième phase la vague bleue où
il a gagné la montée du front national
n'épargne pas la bourgogne en 1992 jean
pierre soisson est devenu président de
la région avec l'appui des voix du parti
de jean marie le pen
une première dans l'hexagone la sphère
créé une controverse nationale
j'ai été deux fois élu président du
conseil régional de bourgogne
une fois avec une majorité de gauche 92
et une fois avec une majorité de droite
à 80,18 et poursuivre la même politique
la mienne en quatre-vingt douze j'ai
profité d'une mésentente dans
l'opposition sans doute élu avec des les
voix du front national en donner ses
voix socialistes et d'une voix
centristes avant d'accepter
j'ai téléphoné à françois mitterrand
pour lui demander conseil que dois je
faire
et il déjeunait avec pierre bergé dans
un bistrot des halles
il a pris le téléphone et m'a demandé
quelle était la situation
si j'avais obtenu des voix du front
national oui nous avons obtenu des voix
du front national
je ne sais pas dans quel temps quelle
mesure il a eu ce mot qui qui les crée
la politique et conduisez qui n'était
pas une vision morale du front national
mais une vision politique
il m'a dit utiliser les mesneux dépend
déjà mes deux fils reprend quand on a la
bourgogne au la garde pour les
régionales de 1998
soissons qui est choisi comme candidat
par la droite démissionne de la mairie
d'auxerre il est de nouveau élu à la
région grâce aux voix du front national
je regrette encore les conditions dans
lesquelles j'ai été élu je porte la
proie de que ceux qui disent ça sont
réélu avec les voix du front national
mais je n'ai jamais passé le moindre le
moindre accord a vu que j'en avais pas
besoin
la double controverse au sujet du front
national poursuivra encore longtemps
l'enfant de paul bert et de l'abbé
deschamps comme ici lors d'une séance de
dédicace de l'un de ses ouvrages
[Applaudissements]
jean pierre soisson est probablement
l'un des hommes politiques ayant le plus
exercer de mandat
à une époque où l'on ne se posait pas la
question de leur cumul à paris il a
connu 50 ans de vie parlementaire
parfois agités
l'assemblée s'est fait au front pour moi
trois endroits dans l'hémicycle le lieu
où l'on vote la loire où l'on craint des
tirs parfois il ya un long moment le
silence l'assemblée s'endort puis une
phrase la réveille et tout d'art par cd
musique
et puis un canton petit l'hémicycle les
couloirs tout autour et député de que
vienne et camarades ils se serrent la
main ils se tutoient et puis un lieu où
on peut travailler seul avec soi-même
c'est la bibliothèque
je suis rentré dans cette bibliothèque
crevé à peine 30 ans était souvent assis
en face d'aimé césaire j'étais devenu un
peu son secrétaire celui qui dit porter
les livres qui a bien aussi le bonheur
échangé quelques propos avec lui au coût
de la mémoire politique du pays se
trouve dans ce lieu
en 2012 à l'âge de 78 ans le vieux lion
d'auxerre tire sa révérence il ne se
représente pas mais il veille à adouber
un successeur propos poursuit une
carrière politique
l'important c'est de savoir sortir de
réussir sa sortie en 2012
je choisis mon successeur a été mon
suppléant guillaume larrivé car son
brillant membre du conseil d'état l'un
des futurs que cette paix devant lui
c'est lui moi c'est moi
bien sûr nous sommes différents mais
c'est une chance formidable de pouvoir
aujourd'hui lui parler échanger
il a toujours un regard extrêmement
affûté sur la france d'aujourd'hui
on parle beaucoup par exemple l'ensemble
des manuels macron c'est ainsi pour
comprendre ce qui se passe ce qui se
joue à députés et l'assistante sociale
votre contribution
chacun est venu me voir pour me confier
semaine après semaine c'est ses secrets
ses difficultés et ça quand je suis
parti j'ai tout détruit tous les
documents qui m'avait été remis par les
uns et les autres
en cinquante ans de mandat politique ça
les regarde et ça me regardait ça ne
regarde personne d'autre
[Musique]
je pense que jean bien soissons et le
dernier duc de bourgogne est la dernière
personnalité à avoir à ce point incarné
dans sa chair dans son coeur dans sa vie
notre région de bourgogne dans qu'il
nous ferait qu'en terre on avait la
conviction qu'ils nous ressembler il
était un bourguignon de souche qui
aimait se lever pour aller travailler
mais qui aimait la gappe qui aimait la
convivialité des gens ce qui lui
permettait d'avoir des échanges d'idées
et puis l'ivresse des mots est aussi
importante que l'ivresse des sens et je
trouve que ça c'est bien notre
tempérament de bourguignons un petit peu
frondeur de temps en temps
pour pas dire beaucoup mais c'est notre
caractère c'est ce qui nous donne un
sentiment de liberté
la bourgogne le village bourguignon les
villages du vignoble roma c'est un peu
le le contraire de paris le
l'embrouillamini politique parisien
ce sont des lieux de ressourcement vous
le respire mieux
je suis d'une certaine façon on peut
approcher dieu les services rendus les
liens politiques et les amitiés sincères
quand un homme politique bourguignon
tire sa révérence la plus belle des
récompenses est peut-être celle offerte
à jean pierre soisson par son ami alain
geoffroy vigneron
alors j'ai toujours peur du cadeau que
tu peux recevoir
il reprend mon frère un vase de soissons
aimant faire en réalité une vie est
l'art de vigne j'ai pleuré
c'est le plus beau cadeau que j'ai
jamais reçu c'est ma petite vigne se
trouve pas très loin de navan des vous
de chasse où mon grand père avait
l'habitude de se rendre
pour casser la croûte abidi c'est la
cabane à 300 dans la région je me suis
dit on va appeler mavinga kaman à
soissons 1 à geoffroy à la fin d'année
m'apporte 60 bouteilles qui sont vendus
comme propriétaire de la cabane à ce
récent
[Musique]
jean pierre soisson c'est à la fois
auxerre l'a puisée le département de
l'yonne c'est à la fois la bourgogne je
me suis souvent promené à ses côtés j'ai
parcouru tous ces territoires
ces territoires se retrouve en lui pour
cette figure de la politique nationale
le mandat qui symbolise plus que tous
les autres son attachement à sa terre
natale
c'est celui de maire pendant 27 ans jean
pierre soisson à incarner sa ville un
engagement à l'ancienne comme il n'en
existera peut-être plus jamais la plus
belle francfort un homme politique ce
n'est pas d'être député ce n'est pas
d'être un ministre sauf dans des
ministères exceptionnelle la plus belle
structure politique en france c'est
d'être mère sont unis par le mariage
ya pas de mystère dans tout ça du
travail qu'est l'amour des gens abondé
jean faut aimer les gens pour faire de
la politique pour une mêlée et touches
et les caressait les embrasser et puis
l'amour du pays dont il est originaire
donc ce travail à mende oublier la mort
des gens c'est ça la recette y en a pas
d'autre
[Musique]